[音楽]
ん
ダボ
ええええええ
これのみなさまはじめましてこんにちは私は歓楽街すすきのでおよそ90年ほど前に
建てられた古民家を改装しそこで文化活動を行っております
石川敬子と申します
もともとは古民家の鑑定士として道内にある古い建物を残すことや
活用するお手伝いなどを行ってきました
今日はこのかもかも堂という建物を通して
薄なので貴重振り返る時に皆さんを連れしたいと思います
すすきのといえばネオ輝く歓楽街としてのイメージをを持つの方が多いのではないかと
思います
そのだんちょ知れば松戸名方が変わってくるかもしれません
その前に少し私が古民家を好きになった理由をお話ししたいかと思います
私は子供の頃から喘息を患っていたため非常に体が弱く
教団や近所の子どもたちと遊ぶほどの体力がなかったんですね
一人でおままごとをしては疲れて寝コミ本を読んでも疲れて熱までて寝込むといったね
本当によく熱を出せ寝込むような子供だったんですね
で横になっている間何をしていたかと言いますとお友達って店長なんですね
天井の向こう側を創造してこの上に部屋を作るとしたらどんな塀を作るだろうか
結構熱波で皆さん想像した方いるかと思うんですね
あとですね本当に寝てばかりいたのでこの転送いたを踏み抜かないように素早く走る
方法てないだろうか
です
とか
に改良向こう向いてよくを見た時に壁があるんですね
その隣には部屋があるんですけど壁と壁の間に人が通れるぐらいの空間があったら
面白いんじゃないか
そういったねあの構想の中を建物の構想の中を楽しんで遊ぶようなことをしていたん
ですね
ですのでその建築というものは自分にとってもとても身近なものでかつ安心できる空間
でありました
建築工学会進んだんですけれども
オフ楽そうした要素期の体験というものが大きく影響したのではないかと思います
学生の頃はとにかく敗としてお金を貯めては列車に乗り込んで古いは津波を見たり
古民家の観察などしていました
実際に古民家の普及活動とはどんなことをしてたのかといいますと
リノベーションをするですとかあとですね
古民家のマッチング仲介をするそういった活動をしてました
そした活動を続ける中でこぎんかというものはただその建物に携わった人々の経歴が
だけが残っているわけではないということに気づいたんですね
築50年なら50年分の軸90年なら90年分の建物の周辺の記憶
古民家はその地域がどんな様子だったのかということを伝えることができる媒体である
ということに気づいたんですね
一つの建物を残すということだけではなく地域のアイディンティティを伝えるために
伝えるための集団となるようにそれを具現化していくようになりました
縁があって顕在化のかも道と呼ばれているこの建物に出会った時
建物は空き家になって3年ほど経過しておりました
痛みがかなりひどい状態ですが私はその子のたたずまいを見た時ですね
この建物って芸者納期やだったんじゃないかなというふうに思ったんですね
皆さん傾斜の沖あってご存知ですか
傾斜さんというのはわかりますかおざ好きでね宴会で高場を盛り上げる方々なんです
けれども
普段から円買いがあるわけではないんですね
お声がかかるまでごした置屋さんというところで待機をして
三味線とか長唄オスながら待っているという場所だったんです
一大歓楽街としてのすすきのですが最盛期には
し50件ほどのお座敷を持つ割烹料って
そういったものがありましたそして最盛期には350人ほどの経営者さんもいたそう
です
馬でこそ高層ビルやホテルなどが立ち並ぶすすきのなんですけれども
かつてはシダレヤナギがこのように値下がっており
そして着物姿の芸者さんたちやあるいは
人力さなどが往来するような非常に風情のある町並みでした
そんなすすきのの街角に佇む古民家のオーナーをしているとその歴史を折に触れて
感じることができます
現在の末の意外な一面を知る為にはその生い立ちをするのが一番です
ここからはススキノの歴史またそこに住んでいた人々の埠頭リーを少しお話ししたいか
と思います
今で北海と命名150年と言われておりますが
当時のススキノというのはまだかや野原でした
北海道と命名される少し前のことですが国内では戊辰戦争という内部風葬が起こって
おり
a 持ちに札幌となるこの地で歯をとあるお侍さんが農村を作るためにお堀を作ってい
ました
お侍さんの名前は大友亀太郎と言います
今みたいに携帯のらしょもないような時代なので
そのため太郎さんがどのぐらい戦なことを知っていたのかは分かりませんか
俺が完成した
頃には戦が終わりおよそ260年続いた
徳川幕府が敗れたためにこの大友亀太郎という侍さんは失業していました
ちなみに
こちらですねこの堀なんですけれども
名前をオート登りと言います
今の創生川の源流となっています
さてこのお堀のミスなんですけれども
カムかもどの脇を流れる小さな鴨々川という川があります
このミスを引いてこの堀は作られているんですが
お侍さんが一人で堀を掘ったわけではないんですね
沢山のと工さん達ど子さんというのは今のと僕作業員のことです
そういった方々がいい
この堀を作るために中止したと根掘りの周辺には彼らの住まいができておりその付近に
はお酒やタバコ
料理などは付かず今で言う居酒屋みたいなお店ができていました
そうしたお店には買収付送付といった女性がつきものだったんですね
これは江戸時代から続く古い風習でした
日本海沿岸には春から秋にかけて主に東北から来た様子たちが
季節労働さとして北海道の漁場に出稼ぎに来ていました
そこには漁師さんたちだけではなくてその相手をする女性たちも一緒にわたってきてい
たんですね
労働する男性たちがいるところにはそうして体を張ってお金を稼ぐ女性たちがいる
これが長い二週だったんですねうからある週間だったんです
この創成川の付近というのも海と陸との違いはあるにしてもやはりあの男性たちが肉体
労働するという場であったため
石狩とかそういった沿岸部からそのゾロやというものが流れて移り住んで来ていました
大友堀の関節の時期と同じ時期に
僕が幕府というのは倒幕されたんですね
その政権というのは幕府から明治政府へと移り変わりました
蝦夷地は北海道と改名されそれまであった
みる制度などが失われるなど一般の人々のクラスというのは非常に大きく様変わりをし
ました
特に先ほど行ったをサムライさ節ですね
完全に次をしてしまいますこの時代というのは大量な失業さが生まれたという混乱期
だったんですね
そうした中で明治政府はこの札幌という地に新たな街をつくることにいたしました
ところが開拓者の中には報酬だけをもらってそそくさと逃げていく人であったり
あとねやはりや北海道って雪国で非常に寒さが厳しいです
その寒さに待機ですに逃げ出していく人などが多く
開拓の削ぎというのは非常に作業が困難だったと言われています
ん
をしたが労働者の足止めのために彼や野原であった原野出会ったすすきのの真ん中に
ススキの遊学というものは作られました
こちらですね初めはですねこの腰壁ぐらいの高さで土を盛り上げて盗塁なんですけども
ねこのように四角い
土塁を築き上げてその中に粗末な建物を7発見作りこの中には
創成川付近で作られたその早漏さ
私がいるお店ですねそういったものを治めていたと言われています
さてこのすすきの遊郭の歴史を語るにあたって欠かすことができないのはそこで働く
女性たちについてです
一般に遊郭といいますと京都の島原遊郭ですとか
後江戸の吉原由香里ですとかねゆれっ子の遊女たちがいて検断豪華な着物を着てくるお
客さんというのもお金持ちの旦那衆であったりねそういったがなんですね
ところがこのすすきの遊郭というのは開拓に精を出すと降参竜のために作られたため
非常に
そういうようなものと言いますかね例えばですね話す言葉といったら
東北から移り住んできた女性たちが多かったので
津軽弁ですとか何度でね北海道の
をスマ地方にいたぞ急いでるとか浜言葉で話す刀
多かったんですねできているものというのも気
古巣たようなちょっと薄汚れたような気も度で
で北海道ってやっぱり寒いので火鉢がそのいうが口の中にあって
ゾロサン立つというのはうつらうつらと居眠りをしているような姿を見られ程度より
当時のことを記録したもので非常にや日た雰囲気を持っていた下品な雰囲気
になったというふうに言われています
こうした状況でも開拓に精を出すとこうさんたちはススキの遊郭に通うようになりまし
た
その中でも双璧と呼ばれている腕この遊女たち2人が現れてきました
一人は越中屋という遊郭の大鍋本名は美味しいという名前だったそうなんですね
彼女は石狩の遊学から流れてきた女性と言われています
生まれつきですね片耳が欠けていたそうなんですけれども彼女ですね
このたい鍋という名前の由来どこから来たのかといいますと
漁村で働く漁師さんたちが食べる
石狩鍋のことダイナ米とも言うんですねこれどんなものかといいますと
料理屋さんでは出さないような魚のあらですとかね
いわゆる二てるような部分5ごった煮してできたようなお鍋だんだそうです
なので彼女の風貌があまりにも酵素やなものなのでダイナでという風に呼ばれたと言わ
れています
とてもひどい顔という意味でつけられた名前なんですけれども
どの文献にも本当にあの稀にみるブサイクだったというふうに記載されているんですね
けれども彼の外のようなすごくねあの
経営者さんでは何かの the 好きの場を持つことに長けている女性だったんですね
自然と人気が江泊していてですね
その名前っていうのはススキの遊郭の中だけではなく東京にも鳴り響いたと言われてい
ます
でそんな彼のそうなんですけれども遊郭のロー主審のことを下ろしてていますねご主人
さんが抱い仲良く働いたねということで
髪結いさん髪の毛をねこういう形のところにお嫁に嫁がせてくれたということでえゆか
蔵は足
が抜けています
そしてもう一人第なべさんと人気を二分した女性がいます
この方は北海入ろうという遊学の女性でアメリカでという方でした
彼女の呼び名もその風貌によって付けられたものと言われています
なんということでしょうか嵐にさらされ
目も鼻も口もあるべきところにないというくらい
この顔のバランスが乱れているということで雨風というふうに付けられたと言われてい
ます
けれども雨方も大変な芸達者で自分の店を持つぐらいにお金をね
稼ぐことができましたそして大出生をした後に結婚して子供まで設けることができた
そうです
遊郭という女性が性を得る場では親の殺菌の肩代わりなどで裏で来られてくる娘さん達
ですとか
貧しくンって貧しくても変わら漆かどうしようもないというような女性たちが働いて
来るような場所だったんですね
で明治の速記の女性たちの平均真相というのは150センチぐらい
私より10センチぐらい小さいくらいなんですねとても小さな体で肉体労働さを相手に
日々働かなくてはいけず短い生涯を迎える女性たちが多かったと言われています
この名前が残る雨風とた稲毛という素性たちはその時代に生きた女性たちの憧れと言い
ますか
頭心体のね女性の幸せを象徴して
このように語り継がれているのかもしれません
また回滝のススキノなんですけれども
はい早い時期にですねたくさんのお寺が出来ました
その背景には徳川の石鹸を築いた徳川家康が江戸時代のですね政権を築いた徳川家康が
浄土宗の信者であったため徳川政権の庇護下にあった珍というのは頭が吹く後にパチ歯
が弱くなり
布教活動という名のもとに開拓移民症例
の1役を担っていた部分もあります
お坊さんたちにも書いた気があったということになりますね
こと名刺3年にすすきのから少し離れたところにあります東本願地なんですけれども
こちらが徳川幕府と非常に縁が深かったために明治政府に目をつけられてしまいまして
北海道開拓のために道路を作るようにと
ねじられております
当時19歳であった東本願寺の若様
件予想人と言います
彼がですね京都から札幌まで
行脚させられそして移民と詳細鬼神
寄付ですねそういったものを募りながら札幌までと
わたってしてその後日本癌地道路という道を切り開いています
この道路なんですけれども国道235線のベースとなっておりまして現在でも多くの
人々が利用している
道の姿勢となっています
このようにススキの遊郭という街は新しいまちをつくるために
花松とてだましで形成された歴史を持っています
さてかもかも道から少し意外なすすきのの成り立ちをお話ししました
もしかもかも堂という建物が芸者の置屋だと気付くことがなかったらこの建物はとっく
に解体され今このように
すすきののアイデンティティーを皆さんにお伝えすることができなかったかもしれませ
ん
150年前に北海道と命名した探検家
松浦武四郎は父親にこう言ったそうです
庶民の子がなを立てることなどは途方もないということだけれども毎日食べているご飯
や
きているものす v へはすべて
庶民の手でつくられたものであり庶民の力なくしてはどうしてこの世の中が上がること
でしょうか
私はこうした動きを知りたいのです
旅には生きた学問があります
何気ない松波なんですけれどもこのように歩いてみるとみなさんも何か大きな発見を
するかもしれません
今ね携帯を見ながら歩いている方って多いんですけれども
ちょっとだけ顔を上げて松波を見てみると
a 数十年前数百年前に残したかもしれない
誰かが残したかもしれないそういった痕跡に出会い新たな知識とかそういったものが
見つけられるかもしれません
こちらで終わりとなります
[拍手]